各位同學大家晚安
调整一下這個位置
你要先從我的單子
我又忘記把麥克風拉過來了
各位要先從我的單開始講嗎
我今天有一股怒氣
就是這個
這兩個部位其實是我
我跑去看電影
然后我根本没有看盘
所以我忘记取消我的挂单
但是不爽的是他曾经赚钱
然后这杯打掉
所以这一段其实让我
这整个戏里面就一个怒气闷在那边
然后接下来这个
怎么头摸一下
失败还好
然后这边
这个被打掉
然后这边又不爽了
到目前为止这样
所以今天目前赔1000多
这个要是再被打掉
我今天一定要绑手
再不绑手
下一步就是赔3000
大概是这样子
然后我刚刚也同时间
在差不多的位置
我在这里
但是我不是在1分K吃
我是在5K吃的
我吃同一个小纳的单子
在这边
好了
那我们来讲解一些东西
我们看一下同学的
赔钱的单跟上了
是不是
我也会赔钱啊
台子有想法吗
在问我之前你有想法吗
因为如果单纯问我的想法
我随便跟你讲一讲
你可能就信了
这样很危险你知道吗
台子有想法吗
我如果说
做多
你就真的做多吗
我说不要做多
空头
做空
你就真的做空吗
好像也不是
所以其实重点不在我的嘴巴怎么讲
你问我有没有想法
对吧
重点在于
你问问题之前
你自己要先有一个
一个一个
好
我觉得台子这边
是压力区
我不想要做多
老于你觉得呢
如果是这样子的话
我的回答是帮得上忙
因为我可以从你的计划里面
就看得出来
你后面的逻辑
这样子我们的对话
是有效率的对话
对吧
好不好
同学们
我不是真的想要念你
我是想要让大家知道说
说我们这边能够帮得上忙的地方在哪里这样你在看台子5分K有个支撑想做多5分K对吗你这样讲那你刚刚就做了
这里啊
就这里啊
可以啊
如果你坐在这边
我觉得你做多的点还不错啊
而且是坐在大刻度的边界
对吗
如果你做这样
你这样子的讲话
这就是一个很棒的说
这样我就看得懂
你想要做什么
对不对
OK
台子旗的月底月初该怎么看
好来
这个是个好问题
我们还原到日线
月底月初刚好出现在这个地方
尖尖的边界
这个地方
它刚好出现在在这里对吧
那如果是这样子
它不小心把这一段整理走上去
那不就到四万九
大概五万这附近
我不确定会不会有
说真的这个不关我的事
但是如果你是吃在这附近的人
很值得今天才9月1号
我很值得给他抱抱看
那会发生什么事我不知道
但是通常我们往常的惯例是
9月是一个很难拿捏
很难捉摸的一个月
原因是因为9月18号
像这一次9月18是美国的这种所有期货
包含个股也好
选择权也好
包含美股这几个大期货
的结算日
所以有这么多结算日在那边
它其实容易受到市场上面
那些大户的进出的干扰
所以这个
这个坦白讲
9月份
我自己过去的经验
相对起其他的月份
更难捉
更难抓
以前比较好抓的往往是
例如说10月11月
就是中间这两个没有结算的月份
或是7月8月
6月也不见得好抓
但是7月8月的这种
常常走一波上
我只下这样子
OK
我今天的单子有观摩的意义
这边
我是在这一根
几乎快要收的时候吃
然后隔壁这边看到下不去再补一个
我这边有10口
就是5加5
然后我拉了一个不赔打掉
这两个单纯是因为这个不爽
看来要被打掉了
这个这样子
上影线看来要被打掉了来我们先来看上面好像有同学有问问题我先看一下好不好我看一下上面的东西
拜托别订阅同学说
打的好球通通抓出来统计
只需要打这些好球就大赚了
来其实以今天而言
我今天正常的出手
这个算是我正常的出手
因为边界二这个
你看哦
正好拿我今天的案例给大家来参考
正常有边界二的出手
是不是比较不容易赔钱
然后这个
这条线
我用系统的话比较明确
这边来看一下这条黄线
这里
这条线的这边其实没有碰到
我还是硬看着这个下影线就去下单
果然没多久就被打掉
而这个呢
你看看这个边界
这个边界
打破边界又回来
所以它的有效性比较高
那我自己的经验
其实我也知道
包含这两单
我在下单前
我其实我就知道
但是那个气有点
就卡在那里
所以我明知道这样子
但是就是不爽
不知道是不是跟那种
那种暑假终于结束
然后小孩子回学校以后
太兴奋有关
没被打掉
所以这个如果省掉
就跟你的结论是一样的
其实我如果不要放宽那么大
底下这两单
其实我比较大的亏损是来自于这个
所以这边我如果不要做
我做这些而已
就算前面这个
因为我没有看盘
如果有看盘至少是不赔
没看盘就是小赔
对吧
那这样子今天这样下来
其实应该也还好
对不对
这边有一个
这个我其实刚好有截图一下
我想要拿到待会的课程里面讲
但是我既然现在看到我就直接讲
有同学说有100万
20万拿来做台子当冲
剩下80万是平均分配四档股票吗
很怕赚钱速度太慢
这位lowlowlow同学你有在线上吗
你有在线上吗?有吗?如果有,我想跟你聊一下
第一个,你为什么怕赚钱速度太慢?你知道赚钱跟赔钱是1比1的速度你多快赚钱其实你就有可能多快赔钱
对嘛
市场不是上就是下
他并没有说上是两倍数
下是一倍数
没有通常都是下还更快
对不对
所以你的思维我必须要先帮你拉回来
第一点就不对
不能用我怕赚钱速度不够快这件事
好你知道吗
你知道你做的台子棋本身带着几倍的杠杆吗
所以你光那20万做台子棋
其实他带来的那个效率跟速度
已经远远超过你的100万
对哦
你20万做的事情
假设你20万全部把保存金压进去
我不知道你能买多少口
反正就刚好压进去
这20万大概会产生20倍左右
大概400万左右的
等于400万左右的单子
但是你总共的资本也不过才只有100万
然后你还要再拿其他的80万去买其他的股票
我不认为这是聪明的举动
这是很危险的事情
赚钱的时候当然很快
因为你带着20倍杠杆的20万做期货
又做了四只股票
赚到很快
但是如果全部都赔钱呢
拜托不要布上我的后尘
我以前就是这样子
想要各种的快
然后就各种的赔
所以我不觉得你这是好事
我觉得如果你有100万
你拿20万来做台子当冲
好
剩下的80万就放在户头
放在那边
那80万是拿来安心用的
他不是拿来用的
不是拿来当做你的保证金余额
让你下单的
他是拿来让你有钱才有胆
你才能好好的遵守
你的交易的纪律跟逻辑
他是拿来做这件事情
不然你干脆分开来
都不要做台子起当冲
因为那会赔很快
你干脆把这100万拿来分3到5只股票
你自己去抓3到5只股票
我不确定是3还是5
都做股票就好了
就是光股票要赔也够你赔的了
那反过来讲要赚也够你赚的啦
对不对
不用开杠杆好不好
然后
正期望值低盈亏比
来讲到这个
我一定要贴一个东西给大家
我刚刚有同学传给我说
他在那个TS的直播上面
他看到了看到了
有我们台湾之光
这个我一定要拿出来讲
我不认识这位同学
我这位Wang W这位
location 台湾
他是TS的竞赛的第一名
太厉害了
我不知道他是谁
然后呢
正好有同学聊到
聊到他的
聊到赚培笔
你看一下哦
他的胜率
来36%
还蛮像我们的做法所出现的胜率
然后他的赚赔比3.35比1
哎呦1000多比327
跟我们平常常见的这种收一下收一下
可能偶尔还是有不赔的单子
或是加上比较大的赚赔比的单子
来平均一下
大概都在这里
好像是
各位他的胜率有没有很高
没有
各位胜率36%
甚至这么多天里面只有四成的日子是赚钱的
其他六成的天数都是赔钱
但是人家赚钱了
而且还是第一名太厉害了
我只是借由他的这个来跟大家讲
你看他赚钱的部位抱着1.4个小时
赔钱的部位9分钟就砍掉
所以他其实就是用着我们一直在讲的方式
只是他的交易法是不是一样的我不知道
但是他的赚赔比跟逻辑是我们一直在讲的东西
有没有真的可以做啊
不是我我没有参加那个比赛
然后所以你说正期望值低盈亏比
这回测下来会赚钱
可是资金回馈感很慢
要反复执行心态真的很难
这倒是真的
因为我们在市场上面我们是人第一的盈亏比的缺点就是你赚可能也一亏也一那你必须要想办法一直获胜
你会特别去惦记着其中一个交易
你放不开来
那对人性的考验真的是太多
我自己知道我的人性面很弱
我的真的很弱
所以我也不打算克服他
我打算就给他比较简单的试子吃
承受小亏损
低胜率
人家三成多的胜率
也不到四成
对不对
跟打棒球一样
三成五的打击率的打者就很厉害了
所以我们就用这种角度
我只要练习着
接受说失败的次数
会稍微高于胜利的次数
今天的我还包含着
去看电影错过行情的那种美颂在里面
这样
OK
好
那我记得上面好像还有东西
我可以聊
春水糖
那个好了
来我来看一下同学的这些股票
买在8月21
同学们果然都是
你看看这些都是老同学的
很会买嘛
很好很好
60k进场
所以当时
哇好美哦
就是这里
就是这个边界
啊好漂亮
只有一个目标290
这样的交易计划可行吗
目标290
来我问你哦
假设你的部位
我用这边拉
这里是231
目标290
现在
现在279你觉得距离你的目标部位是不是差一些些而已
几乎要到了嘛
对不对
那如果我是你
我的做法是现在已经进入了随时要出场的阶段
那我可不可以希望他到290可以啊
但如果明天后天刚好有到280几
现在已经279了
到28585
注意听我讲哦
285 85 85 86 86
重上去87 85 85 87 86 86 85 85 84
出場那個時候那個數字上已經呈現一個尖尖的上癮線的样子我的这个不会卖掉了所以代表我的那个应该下来
好啦 今天不要再做了
我再做下去会死很惨
那也还好啦 我在我的增仓IB那边我用的也是小单子
我在测试而已 还好
所以这个我觉得你心里要有个理由
就是接下來如果繼續噴就繼續抱著
盤中如果你沒機會看
你可能就每隔一小時瞄一下瞄一下
有到280幾了
好啦出
如果出完以後尾盤到290怎麼辦
沒關係啊才差5塊錢而已
沒有差沒有差
不一定要出到完美的那個最高點
對吧
有差不多就已經很好
这位黄琼慧同学
你要问的是3105
文茂8月5号可翻亚当却没出去
那么827可以再翻吗
这根吗
8月5号什么意思
5号可翻亚当
来我跟你说
你其实这一根可不可以翻
你只需要问自己一件事情
它有没有长破一个很久都长不破的点
有
那跟8月5号有没有关系
一点关系都没有
跟8月5号 8月3号 8月几号
管他几号都没有关系
它只跟眼前最近的这个有关系
那你说今天要不要翻
翻啊
那你现在心里就有两种剧本
一个剧本是长这样子
到今天刚好差不多到了
另外一套剧本
这是剧本A
另外一套剧本是哇塞他真的走这么强
这样子上去直接走到这里去上面这里
那哪一套剧本会是
会是最佳节我不知道
你得选一套
那目前看起来今天这么强你可以继续抱着
那你就要注意一件事情是
你现在要先下定决心
明天如果出现震荡你要不要走
现在就要决定
不能等明天
你如果现在决定明天震荡
你觉得就是满足趋了就走了
那就走吧
OK很棒那如果你觉得明天震荡不想走你想要赌这个OK啊那你就要接受可能从500块到甚至到400块
420大震荡
你要接受这件事情
那如果震荡以后没有再回去怎么办
这个都是你要接受的
那我的建议是
如果你是买在底下
如果你是像这样买在底下
上去了对不对
如果你有多部位
我建议是明天就把其中一半的部位先除掉吧
落袋为安
那这时候剩下的呢
反正你有一半已经落袋了
另外一半就随便给他漂
不要理他
这样好不好
你是那位王先生吗
哇就是你哦
是吗
朝圣一下
各位
太强了
我就说了
同学们一个一个都卧虎长龙
比我强的太多了
好来
那我再继续看一下上面
巨大60K有打击区吗
巨大
60k
坦白讲他日线的位置我不喜欢
来
他日线的位置长在一个
一个
大颗度的满足区
然后又是一个
又是一个这种
我这样看
这样
压力区满足区
这样子的这种夹在中间的60k
没有我不觉得漂亮
一点都不喜欢这个60K
没有
如果会让我醒过来的60K
在这张图里面
假设哪一天它跑到这里来
就是震荡震荡跑到这里来
碰这个下面
然后呢在日线打了一个破底的
注意哦破底以后的60K
那这个时候
他应该会在这个地方出现这样子
然后下刹
被买上来
又回来这样子
如果出现这样
你今天跟我说
在这个96 98这附近
60K值不值得观察
我会跟你说
哇这个是很
棒的東西
這樣好不好
周縣若收十字會好東西嗎
周縣
同學的這樣子的問就很很有方向
我就可以知道說該怎麼幫你講解
周縣收十字
好归好
但是就
因为这个十字比较麻烦
它是一个上引线跟下引线
好像差不多大小的十字
所以有停顿
然后前一周很凶嘛
对不对
有停顿
但是这样子
两边都差不多距离会
不知道该怎么去判断这件事
所以我如果是你
我会
要先丟轻轻的部位试试看
你不要先丟重的部位
这样
好不好
来我现在随便看看旁边这些
我看到什么我就念什么
2313滑通
2313滑通日K
是标准图吗
8月
看一下
我现在9点06了
我还没讲到今天的东西
等一下让我先切出去讲今天的东西
我等一下会留时间
特别留时间跟大家聊天
聊大家的股票
如果你现在我没有回答到你的
请留着等一下好不好
这个当做最后一个
然後我等一下講完
我會留時間給大家
2313華通日K是標準圖嗎?
等一下
日K是標準圖嗎?
是但不是在現在
不是在現在
現在是
現在這個位置這裡
這是很危險的位置
所以你8月21買在215
如果你買在215這邊我可以給過
這個樣子可以
因为有那个感觉
打算300出场
我们看一下你的300出场
300出场
那你现在目前为止这就是我刚刚讲的这个小亚当他其实到了你看小亚当到了到了以后他说会出现震荡
开始在震荡
那如果这样子的震荡
你接受的话
下一次如果有机会
就是这个震荡有机会再出去
这个时候你再预估300会比较合理
因为现在你当初涨破这边
你要预估300
他还要先撞破这边
再撞破这边
还要才会到300
好多压力
那些压力都有
你看底下有成交量
套牢的人在这边
他们都会成为未来的卖压
这样
所以短期其实就震荡了起来
好不好
同学们旁边问的
请留着一下
我先回来讲
今天的这个主题
我不会
其实不需要讲太多时间
但是我想要完整的讲一下
然后待会会留时间
再来跟大家聊天
今天的主题是这个
不好的互换
不好的破底翻
我这个形态什么时候烂掉
不能再碰
然后这些是我刚刚原来的截图
所以其实已经很多都已经讲过了
那就这样子吧
OK
来
前面这个主题的第一句话
这个
这个主题所有东西都围绕在该发生却没发生这件事情
就是我们从一些案例来讲
先把这些观念先放在心里面
什么叫该发生
突破新高应该继续出去却没有
类似刚刚那个翻像这种
创新高了他应该要继续出去
结果却没有好
或是出现了涨多跌少的迹象
却没有继续延续
什么意思
我们用台达电来当举例
大家所上有台达电吗
我其实上礼拜
我还跟大家讲
上礼拜的直播正好我们在这边
我就跟大家说我买了
我还多加一个1680的这个部位
然后我们不是说
说它是一个破底翻吗
好
我们进到小的刻度来看一下
注意看
本来是跌多
注意看这边
跌多、涨少、跌多、涨少、跌多、涨不多、跌不多
但是又跌多了
结果这时候开始出现,变成涨多、跌少所以从这一刻起从这个斜斜的斜率有没有涨上来开始它变成涨多跌少
涨多跌少
目前还不知道明天会是继续涨多还是跌下来
那就算它跌下来
它只要维持住涨多跌少
涨多
涨是涨这一段
所以它跌的时候只要能够跌小于这一段
例如说跌到这里跌到1800
那下一步这边如果市场弯上来
有没有可能就继续维持着这一段
把这个涨多跌少
涨多跌少
他就维持住了
那如果明天
没有继续延续
该继续这样变成什么来
注意看哦
整理盘整他整理的起来
结果出现一个
哎呀假设出现这样
那个概念就很不一样
就有点像这边了
因为他整理的起来
开始出现某一个迹象是跌破了
不该跌破的点
如果这样我就知道说
假设在这个地方出现我刚刚画的
出现这样我就知道说
那看来要咚咚
可能要下来这里找
找到边界在哪里
那我就可以锁定他在这个框框附近
我等他在这里
如果他又出现
出现涨多跌少的概念
类似像这些或是像这个这样子
它出现在这里是不是又是一个
很棒的观察点
所以没有说跌破1000基是不是就全卖
没有没有
来
那个SR同学你不能用这种角度来看
因为每个人的进场的价格不一样
每个人的资金规模风险都不一样
所以我们没有办法用一个标准给全部的人
对吗
例如说买在这边的人
跟买在这边的人
他们能够承受的拉回完全不同啊
一个一点都不行
一个稍微回来他都还没事还是赚钱
这边的人呢
就算跌到这里他都没事
他都怎么样都还是赚的
说不定他还可以考虑有下引线的加码
所以我这边先讲这个案例
等一下我们在看大家的股票的时候
我们会有很多机会来看
或是像这个楼梯站上去了缺油掉下来来这边就是一个很经典的案例注意看这边樓梯本来的压力
变成地板
有没有
楼梯一接一接一接的上去像这边
这边是不是站上来了
本来18就是这部分
本来的压力在这几天变成了支撑对不对
结果
本来这边都还有涨多跌少涨多跌少涨多
结果怎么样
1920这里曾经站了三个小时上去
结果却掉下来
那其实也是某种程度的楼梯烂掉
他的惯性是不是不见了
长多跌少 长多跌少 长多跌少
哎呀 怎么变长多
这里应该就要长多了
该发生 却没发生
应该要延续原来的动作
对吧
那我们从同学的这个案例来聊
这是一位同学写信给我
然后他说他常常遇到这种东西
然后就一直停顺怎么办
来我们来看一下
同学的第一个
我们把后面都遮住
我们跟着他来做
第一个这个边界二
这个吃是我我也会吃
我今天就有单子就是像这样吃在这里
对不对
同学吃这边
出现又下沙
这里同学说又吃一次
这里
这个我会吃
因为这边一样有涂鸦的样子
注意看我在做的事情
我用比较厚一点
注意看我的涂鸦
我这是同学的涂
我们等一下用真实行情
这样子我还会
所以我会损一次损两次
停损两次
结果来这一次假设
有机会让我拉不赔
不用讲拉不赔
假设都赔钱
因为是同学画的
叠到这边
同学说这里又吃
这里他又吃
又吃这样子
来各位
我们一起涂鸦
涂鸦到这一瞬间
我们来咯
涂鸦来了
我们从这边开始涂鸦
看我的涂鸦
看绿色的部分
好
请你用这个涂鸦
画出两条线
你会怎么涂鸦
你会怎么定义眼前
上不去的边界跟
下不去的边界
有没有看到我做的事情
在
这个东西出现以前我对他没有反应
因为只有他一个人在下面OK
只有那个一个人在下面的我喜欢
上面这边我仍然会以他
但是只要他多了一个人
一个点两个点两点就会一线
来这句口诀请你背起来
一点两点两点一线
上面也是一样啊上面超过两个点那当然是一线啊对不对
所以這個時候在我的腦袋裡面
中間這一條
我現在畫的這一條
已經沒有意義了
因為它被市場穿過來穿過去穿過來穿過去
反而是邊界變成在這裡
所以在這張圖裡面
你後面講的幼痴是不會發生的
這樣可以理解這個想法嗎
沒有那個幼痴
你了不起頂多前兩次
一个边界二次一个标准图施
你了不起就这两次失败
不会有第三次
这样可以理解
那眼前的盘
我们用现在的盘不知道有什么东西
现在其实就是一路下沙的盘
那我要讲的是
我看一下黄金有没有
黄金一路下沙
黄金有成交量
有下沙
看来黄金准备停住了
我要找一下
原油上不去
来来来
这边正好有一个案例
原油在这里
应该要继续的涨多跌少
涨多跌少
所以如果这边没有继续涨多
突然间来一根
来一根
像这样子的
K棒
再一次
如果这边来一个像这样子的K棒
跑到这里
像这样
光这一瞬间我就知道说
哇这一段上涨的行情来到这里可能怎么样
可能就挂了就没有了
因为就整个力量不应该出现任何一次的这种反转
但是挂了以后不代表之后不会再有做多的援军
但是你接下来再做多你心中就要有底
它的力量已经变成是横向盘整多空两边在那边角力
你打我我打你算是很用力在打仗的地方没有那个兵败如山倒的其中一边输掉了沒有好不好那這時候如果出現這個地方
他稍微上影線縮進來
你要做空
這大概就是我們講的邊界二的位置
然後呢
如果行行是這樣子
注意看我講
在這邊行行是這樣跌下來
我又長上去到8800 8810這附近
開始長出像這樣子的上影線
像這樣子
注意看我畫的圖
跌下來長上來到這裡
像這種東西
哦!你在這邊做空
那就是很聰明的做空
這樣可以理解嗎
因為你已經讓市場先掉一個樓梯下來
然後你才開始在
他都有一點站不穩的
他喝醉酒了有沒有
就順便推他一把把他推下山谷
对我们都是坏人啊
我做多其实也是一样啊
我都在等对面喝酒
然后走路不稳的时候
我才踹他一脚
只是今天我踹失败
不对今天要怪的人是我自己
是我自己喝醉酒
然后没有看清楚
然后就乱下单
从这个案例
黄金不知道有什么东西
还不行
黄金还不行
我没有办法明确的找到你讲的那个点
但是你各位应该可以听得懂
我在这边要带的概念
我们这样一路走过来
那以前的我是在这个地方
一直吃一直吃
所以我重大的亏损的时候都是
我一直奠记着刚刚的价格
假设这条线的价格
这条线价格假设是100好了
明明市场就跌到更低了
但是我都不理他
我就一直对那个100就是念念不忘
好像我被这个女友
她甩了我一巴掌一样
她跟我分手了
但是我就一直想要她的爱
想要追求她
她一直打我
我还是一直要追求她
她大概就是那种感觉
所以这个
我可能会死前两次
ok 但是这个就不会了
这样好不好
今天同一片结束了
好下课
给bruce同学这样可以的吗边界直接重新定义就这么简单那定义边界的好方法
是你用很粗的画笔
很粗的画笔
你去涂鸦这个市场
高低点都要
就是例如说像这个
你要连那个最高
最低
最高点到这里
最低点到这里
你要这样都要涂鸦到
这样子才是有意义的东西
不要没有涂鸦
那有些人会说老鱼下影线我可不可以不要涂
不行哦
很多时候有很多成交量
他是成交在下影线的最末端那里
因为成交量下沙然后被逼出来
很多时候成交量是跑到这里来
所以他有人成交在那里
你就要画出他的价格的动态
好不好
模拟单
模拟练习用跳动比较快的EK
会有助于标准动作吗
其实可以
因为EK的确快
那如果你在练习里面
你用EK
前提是你拿捏得住
我们进到EK去看
其实这EK已经停住了
对啊我看得出来
我先说这些单子我不是EK吃
这个我是EK跟5K
大概都有看到一起吃
这个不是1K吃
这是单纯不爽
这样
然后这个是5K的
然后现在1K来
1K的涂鸦我涂鸦给你看
我换个颜色黄色好了
到这边
到这里
这样子的涂鸦
这样子上下
所以目前在这里
滑鼠没有按好
所以目前我会用这个角度
没有做到多单的人
拜托你等1K出现这个
来
今天正好来聊
什么心音下是好的跟不好的
如果这边
应该要征服这边上去又回来
由上往下踩这边
它应该这样子
但是却在眼前出现了一个
假设这边出现一个这样子
它应该站上去
然后却没有站上去
这是不是我们刚刚讲的
该发生没发生
那这样子回来
就算待会回来在这边
诶鬼混
这已经不是一个好的呼唤了所以我们说图什麼時候會爛掉來當他該發生卻沒有發生
所以這張圖理論上要出現這樣子
他應該要出現
我先把我的那個
遮住
他應該要出現像這樣子的東西
注意看
應該這樣子上去
又回來
我就像這個一樣
又回來這樣子可以喔
我接起來
这样子
有没有 上去
然后整理一下回来
K棒大的在上面
然后在这个边界变小根
如果是这样子
这个图我会很爱它
好吗 这样子
但如果注意看
我刚刚是不是说烂掉的图
但如果今天这个图是这样子
是这样子上去
注意看
他带着长上隐线
虽然有回来
但是他都是带着长上隐线回来这个边界
那这个边界也不好了
也烂掉了
这样知道这个意思吗
好我们再来聊破底翻的概念
今天就有这个概念
这里就有
这里就有来来来
这里是不是一个破底翻
破底翻
对不对
那照道理讲出现破底翻
是不是这里已经出现了
出现了涨多跌少
所以照道理讲
注意听我讲哦
破底翻的这边应该就要出去
应该就要出去
所以如果出现破底翻的后面
他没有维持住那个涨多跌少的惯性
反而在这个地方出现这种上影线
这时候这样下来碰这边
这时候已经跟刚刚的破底翻
没有太大的关系
你可以知道说这是大边界
但是你需要重新等待
等待什么
等待他要重新的把这边打破一次再说了
这样有理解我的想法吗
因为像这个就是一个很好的案例
你看他照道理讲
应该要涨多叠小
涨多叠小
这里其实就要干嘛
该发生涨多
却居然有人
哎呀
这样子直接掉下来
哦
那这个是不对的事情
有没有
该发生
像这边又来一个
本来的小小的涨多跌少
涨多跌少
涨到跌潮 結果哎呀又是一樣
那我們來看現在
哎呦現在有耶 但是他來的樣子來各位
現在這一分K來的樣子
兇不兇
其實蠻兇的
而且他波動又大9.25了
我覺得
如果我是今天前面有賺錢
那我可以在這邊
隨意的測試但我會測試的點可能會在這邊
而不是在这里
我觉得它没有到很漂亮
因为理论上这一根要这样子
它要把这边的一分可以走出去
走到130,125这边
然后再下沙
这样子就好很多
但是它却稍微增幅一点点
增幅多少
105到110
这非常的短
有没有
这个不是我要观察的东西
所以我就回到大科度一点
给那个
我刚刚看到旁边在讲到
SR同学问说
其他人每天亏多少会受不了
我说真的
这真的是科度不一样的关系
我就遇过一个大姐
她曾经亏过一千万
曾经
所以她后来在持仓的时候
亏个十万块钱台币
对她来讲就是
好像是小事啊
因为人家曾经亏过那个钱
而且他户头里可能还有好几千
所以对他来讲十万块没感觉
但是十万块钱对于一个大学生来说
是很大的一笔数字
他怎么样都承受不起
所以我不觉得那个
我不觉得这个事情能够一个
一句话来通用大家
但是我可以讲出一个
常见的金额超过那个
大家容易乱掉的金额
因为这不是只有我自己的经验
我教过那么多同学
访问过那么多同学
我们的经验大概是介于500到800美金
超过这个很容易进入一个
很不爽就是想要把它打回来的境界
所以简单的说
不要让它在一天的亏损超过这个数字
那你说增仓呢
我增仓的亏损我甚至会分两种
我打期货的亏损也是大概在1000美金以内但如果是我拿去打股票的几万美金我都没差因为我打股票的单子我打从一开始用的钱
就已经是闲钱
那个闲钱还不是我存来的闲钱
那已经是市场收刮来的闲钱
然后现在摆在那边让我乱丢股票
大概是这种感觉
所以对钱的那个看法
已经会有点有点不太一样
但是期貨部位我會乖乖的
因為期貨部位我知道
帶著20倍的槓桿我隨便一凹
就凹20倍沒有必要做這種事情
這樣
好不好
來那你說老魚
你現在你剛剛不是說1K我看到
我剛剛其實一秒鐘我看到底下我就知道了
這邊不是要上嗎
對吧
我亂丟股票還有遵守什麼紀律嗎
其實還是有啦
基本上就是长线的下面我会吃
就是那种大颗度然后骨灾
然后大家很恐慌的时候
然后跟最近的那个啊
我最近不是在吃那个那个
台达店就是他
我上礼拜
我还不是还有发文吗告诉大家
对吧但是我我现在手上四张啦
我没有加
我就这四张
我在这边其实有加一些
下来这一天我还有加一些
所以我总共有四张
这样子
最后一个加的那个钱是加在1680
如果全部停损大概就是这边整个打掉
我可能就整个停损了
你说这样会不会赔
会啊会赔啊
我就是赔这边到这边
其实我均价大概就在1700附近
没有到很高
反正就是抓这个附近这样
所以这个我目前的计划
就是
这边
这边是我的第一目标
第二目标就看看他会发生什么事
我会买的股票就那些
星星我没有买过
星星没有买过
对啊
然后我长线
像我长线我会丢的股票
其实就是0050里面
你有看过的一些股票
大概就是这样子
长线下来丢台积电也好
台积电最近我是叫我女儿丢
我自己没有丢
因为我要丢的部位
如果要丢那个部位相对大
所以来我比较一下
同样在丢台积电的图
你要我丢 我丢不下去我就叫我女儿丢个十股他们OK这样然后练习他们那个没有钱的感觉这样所以同样这两张图
我丢的是丢
我是丢这个
那你说我外面还有没有资金可以丢
可以
我一样也可以丢台积电
但是我就是不想在这个地方丢
这样子
好不好
然后
哇
有人出金了90万
今年六到九月间全赔光了
哇塞
第一个
你能够出了90万
代表你一定做对什么事啊
你要不要回头问一下自己
你在能够出金的那个阶段
你到底做对什么事
那你能不能够在接下来几个月
重复的复制你当初做对的事情
这样
那我再猜
你说现在的交易动作出现不好的惯性
我猜你可能偶尔有打出一些暴擊
然后例如说不爽靠一笔大的
20口30口40口50口
然后一出去赚钱
你可能不小心染上了这种习惯
这就跟毒品一样你知道吗
他很赚钱的时候很开心
因为他赚钱的时候
因为你下的部位大
出去很快就赚钱
所以你的心会自然而然的去
黏在那个多巴胺
那个金钱的毒品上
而且有你回不来
你会一直惦记着
一旦下大单就出去
我猜啦
因为那段时间其实很多人
透过这种方式
或是像看Bump的影片
用现货
然后跟那个这样子两个去抓
那我是没有说
很推荐那样子的做法
那样子的做法摆明
你就是在透过各种制度
然后你想办法去把那个钱
从人家的那个平台里面洗出来
大概是这种概念
你说虽然是合法
对 目前也没有说是违法
但是某个程度来说
它不是正规交易做的事情
我们不会这么做
而且记不记得我刚刚片头一开始讲的
那位王同学
这边的那位王同学
他下的部位也没有很大
对吧
每一次人家都有统计
两到三口每一次出手
就两到三口两到三口
赚的时候赚一千
赔的时候赔300多
赚赔比3.55比1这样子所以人家没有做什么很夸张的事情反而细水长流这样慢慢的做然后那些贪图快钱的反而会很容易就
就粘在那边他回不来
我也曾经被粘去过
因为我曾经就有人来酸
我就来酸
我说阿老玉我们那边随便赚都几万美金的
你在这边赚几千美金真的是小咖
坦白讲我真的是小咖
我一点都不觉得我很厉害
尤其在市场上面
我如果当天觉得我很厉害的时候
老天爷会给我重重一拳
让我醒过来
你就是平凡人
你不是超人
那我一样会被他们的那种
人家赚几万美金我也会
我就大胆尻
然后尻几次对了
好爽啊
对
你看
后来
后来我其实花了好一段时间
大概可能半年有
我才把那段时间沾染上的那个习气
就是那种大单的习气给缩回来
但是现在我又调整到中间就是
我还是会大单
但是我是大单在该出手的那些地方
而不是随意的乱赌的那种大单
这样
Bump的套利
你自己去搜寻影片
我不確定他有沒有下架
应该还在
你就搜寻Bump
他们用增仓跟这种考试账号
两个部位做多空的对冲
这样
反正就是一直洗
有人说老鱼果然是过来人
对嘛
但是刚刚我不是在片头
我就秀给大家看那个那位王同学嘛
人家慢慢做还是可以这样子耶
所以在这个市场不怕你慢
他怕你急
怕你不对反过来说
这些平台他就是要你急着想赚钱
市场上的对面的那些可能外资也好
可能你说的大户也好
他就是要大家急
你越慢他越赚不到你的钱
你越急你会越快的把钱
无论是用刷卡大量的刷卡
或是用赔的方式赔给对方
他们就是想办法让你挤
然后给你各种声光效果
或是赌场里面的美女
挤
然后他的目的就是让你麻醉你的神经
让你慢不下来
那我们每个礼拜在这边
就是要大家慢一点慢一点
希望能够帮你调一下调一下
这样
对他不能玩是因为就是平台也知道他在洗这些钱
所以平台也会抓他
那他们这种模式
你知道这种模式我讲解一下好了
它只适用在真实的账号
对上一个人家那种考试的平台
而且只有特定的规则才有效
就是那个规则刚好是有利的
好
它只适用在这里
这种多空对冲的模式
是无法活在真实世界的
我在同一个价格做多
坐在凯基
另外跑去群艺
同一个价格做空
两边对冲
你在干嘛
这没有意义
我曾经在同一个券商开两个账号
一个账号做多
真实很久以前的事情
一个账号做空
想说待会行情出去
我就保留其中一边
然后把另外一边砍掉
然后让它喷
这样就赚到小赔
然后大赚
没有
最后的结果永远都是
这边小赔的我砍掉
最後那個要噴出去的也不噴了
然後就縮回來兩邊都停損
靠北
明明是對沖的
但是兩邊都可以做到停損
大家懂嗎
這個
哭哭
MQ的5K
真的嗎
不要
各位
他應該要繼續往這邊走
現在很亂
等一下
等一下,眼前的这个上影线盒蛮讨厌的
好不好,这个不好
OK
我女儿会下单
他们有开那个,我带他们去开券商的户头
我之前未成年还要加账
然后反正就开嘛
就给他们,把他们的压岁钱也好
平常考試我們就是學校可能偶爾會有拿到獎學金我要考的好的对然后就存起来我说就拿去丢股票乱丢都好这样有人说完全理解对不对对啊
没有对冲基金不就是骗人不是哦
对冲基金不是这样子
然后我讲解一下对冲基金
我来讲解
例如说
我们就以航运股就好 航运股大家应该很熟
2603来航运股有台湾比较常
常见有三个吗
长荣
万海
阳明三个吗
他们是这样子
例如说都三个都是航运股
然后他们会
做多
他们比较觉得比较强势
比较好像比较会长的那个
然后做空
比较弱势的那个
同样是航运股里面
所以他就希望
这个比较强的比较会赚钱的可能继续赚
这个最近比较弱的这个好像就上不去
所以一个做多一个做空
但是是不同的股票不是同一支
我刚刚前面讲说骗人的那个是做在一模一样的小纳
那个是没有意义的
对吧
我说的是不同的股票
他们切开来
我做多这个航空股也好
做空这个航空股也好
反正就是类似的族群他去挑
他怎么挑不要问我 反正就是他去挑
他的目的就是去赚多的会赚比较多
然后弱的这个会维持弱弱的
他赚中间的价差
这个就是他赚的
这个叫做对冲基金
这样
所以Hedge的最一开始的定义是避险
所以如果我做多了某一支航运股
那我就去做空另外一支航运股来避他的险
这样子
大概是这种概念
OK
所以那个跟我们现在讲的完全不一样
那我跟各位说
这种AB账
一个账户做多一个账户做空
假设这边赔5000
这边赔5000这边就赚5000嘛
一模一样的部位嘛对不对
就有一些市面上的人会拿这样子的截图
因为他就只要截赚的那边的图
跟你说他赚5000
那你就说哇我好厉害
大大好厉害教我教我
一门课程50万
外面很敢开真的你只看到是其中一边的截图事实上它是無風險帳號因為它兩邊賺賠就打平了
頂多就手續費而已
隨便騙一個50萬手續費就有了
對不對
這樣
好啦 來 我們來看一些市場上面的東西
然後來聊
來讓大家聊說我們剛剛講的那個標準圖
該出去沒出去爛掉或怎麼樣的概念
好不好
這邊我隨便看 大家可以繼續留言
去留言
我就隨便看 我看到什麼就講什麼
這個嗎
日K824那天算標準圖嗎 你應該是在講
這邊對不對
這邊嗎
來 標準圖的概念是塗鴉嘛 對不對
我塗鴉給你看
涂鴉到这里
那我为什么会涂鴉到这边
因为它底下这个价格
其实碰过碰过碰过好几次
所以这个跟破底翻比较没有关系
它唯一比较能有点牵强的概念是
这里有一个小互换
这边
跟这个边界这样子
顶多就是这样子
但是以图形来讲
他没有到很好去拿捏
主要是底下这个东西跟这个人
还有这些人
他让边界跑到这边来了
所以有点讨厌这样子
好不好
来那再来
3711日月光
所以吃在581预计650出
我看一下
你吃在581大概在這附近
可能是今天可能是昨天對不對
來如果是這個你要抓破底翻
我比較可以給過
然後你的計畫是做到哪裡
650出一些725左右全出
可以啊這計畫很OK
沒有什麼問題
那為什麼我會說
這個你說要抓破底翻比較合理
是因為你看哦
他这里有一个蛮明确包含这个跳空这个
这些人的价格的边界还蛮干净的定义在这个地方
所以你在底下这里守
守这种边界,这个比较比较好防守这样1795是吗
美食
上面问
1795看一下 你要看的是看什么
你要看破底翻对不对
来我跟你说
现在这个位置
可能要在周线会比较明显
因为
周线其实我知道它这里有东西
但是眼前是不是一两周正在往下
所以如果有机会可以回到比较偏下园这个
就是现在这个地方
这边会很美
如果有机会来到这里
其实现在差距不大了
坦白说
但是因为现在它正处在跌多涨少
目前还在跌多的状态
而今天的这一根十字线
虽然有做多但是
有点尴尬
就是这边压力
这张图
尴尬了
长线来讲我觉得大边界是对的
只是他短线的样子
没有很爱
好不好
SR同学你应该是中国的股票来看一下
我也不知道是什么
我刚刚最前面是不是看到有瞄到有人问那个
问比特币啊
那个你可以再问一次吗
我可能已经找不到比特币了
然后你要问我的是什么呢
SR同学
标准图右边肩膀低于左边
要不要剃掉
标准图
哪里有标准图
右边肩膀
你是指
我沒看錯 301171
對啊是這一支
你是指這邊嗎
我現在聽不懂你講的這個
等一下我再繼續回答好不好
我們來看其他的東西
8150日線今天算是可以
南茂日線今天嗎
今天早上可以
但是到尾盘这边
你距离人家找盘的价格其实就有一段路
我不喜欢我的单子是撞在这种
撞墙的地方
但如果你是早上你吃在这个地方
90块附近这里
可以
等一下我回头看一下
对不起
我看到周线一下
微微的尴尬了一点
因为你单纯看这个尖尖的
对不对
我是看不到太明确的标准图
因为标准图理论上要出现在这个地方
就是我这样看到的这边
没有到很漂亮
也不是我熟悉的标准图的样子
对啊 你看那个
我刚刚不是讲那个谁
当然借我讲一下
因为2308最近那个图真的很漂亮
这个日线的这个图就
真的很标准啊
就是对吧
就是这个概念
我再继续看后面的好不好
2371大同买在8月12开盘算是好位置吗
2371买在8月12
12的开盘是好位置吗
你抓这个长下影线这个
这个感觉我觉得我知道你在抓什么
那买在这边开盘那我要问一下
你当初买在这边你的防守在哪里
因为他前面的引线很长
如果你说你防守在这边
可以我给过虽然长但是我给过啊
你就防那个点
你说如果你只是防中间防这里
他又距离这个边又好近
所以这个点的唯一的缺点是他太靠
上面比较不好防守是太靠这边
这样
好不好如果当初你是防到这下面去
好 给过 你大概是用日线加周线的概念
在吃它这个边界这样子
所以前一根的第一点对吧
那如果是这样子
这样子可以给过
但是防守真的很长
所以如果单纯从位置来看
后面几天因为打了一个这样子撞墙的这样
你在这天的开盘吃
尴尬了一点
因为前面有这种大的上限
对啊下一次如果你有遇到这样子有遇到上面你可以稍微做一个变化有点小变形怎么变
假设你要吃10等份的部位
你在这边有点急没错
你先吃个3等份就好了
以内1到3等份
剩下的7等份
如果接下来几天还在这边
你再把剩下的7等份的钱
吃完
反正你本来就要吃10等份的钱
你就把它吃完
跟你一次吃是一样的
这样试试看
好不好
还有
同学很好笑
60K买入28点多
你买的点很好
各位来
这个60K就是很标准的
就是那种边界这样子
所以很多人会在这里
就觉得说
这里好像有东西可以吃
这就是我们讲太靠上缘的概念
反而这边下面28这里就很漂亮
你女儿现在两岁
能否抱到那边
我不知道
不过你的
旋骨也很棒啊
这个周线也很美
这种尖尖的这样子
你的等待很好很好
可以啦
你有这种耐心
你女儿应该会继承到你的耐心的
黄金15k跟小娜15k
小娜的15k
我们先看黄金好了
黄金15k
黄金15k现在没有东西可以吃
没有机会
没有任何15k的机会
15k如果要有机会
要这样子
到这样子
可能要好几个小时以后的事情
现在没有它的事情
所以现在的行情了不起在
5k也没有
了不起在1k
1k也是只有这里
顶多只有这边可以摸
现在行情很快
原油
来原油我们刚刚不是想说
如果这边下来了再上来才是好东西
做空
如果想要做空的人你会看着原油然后没有动作这样不是帮你省了一些钱吗对不对你就不会去逆着趋势去做空你会等到来注意
应该继续走
但是却没有继续走的情形下
跌下来你才去踢他一脚
对吧
好
然后
所以刚刚的小娜同学问说
这个位置这样收拾标准图在走吗
坐边的方
我知道同學打字很快
NQ現在位置這樣收
給這位JJJDDD同學
你這樣講
例如說你說這個位置
我無法知道是1分K的這個位置
還是5分K還是3分K還是2.5分K
還是15K的這個位置
每一個刻度
你所看到的東西都不一樣
所以你必須要很明確的跟我講
1分K的這裡或哪裡怎麼樣
我才有办法根据你的思维去找到你的那个点
不然这个位置日线吗
我有可能啊
对吧
所以我们从问题本身要再回来
它就是你的交易计划
你要能够问出一个有明确定义的交易计划
这样才是一个负责任的trader
这样
所以我这样子我没有办法告诉你
是什么叫做视标准图在走吗
其实标准图的概念也不是代表稳赚不赔
我们如果出现那种好的标准图
我会下单
那还是可能会赔钱
只是因为它长期下来
我们统计过后发现
那样做好像长期下来的效率不错
亏亏赚
三次里面种一次
多出来的这些钱
其实足够我前面两次的亏损
那我只要心态不要像我今天这样乱掉
我只要维持住该要做的事情
那我就是赔赔赚
同样的图一直做
所以眼前我不知道
什么叫做是不是标准图在走
不重要
重要的是来这句话很重要
他待会走到哪边可能会出现标准图
如果他待会走来这里
这里有个边界
我是不是就可以把标准图
好那我就可以来这里
观察这个边界
等一下可能就来了那来的时候又有几个前提如果他来的时候是用这种大K棒的样子一路下插的来这个边界就我们告诉你的做法
要不要等
要我不能直接吃
要等什么
等市场像这样子一样的
干嘛
如果这个东西出现在这里
好
你出现在这一根5分K
等他上下震荡震荡震荡震荡震荡震荡
停住
停注射的隔壁你就很好防守了
然后获利点也很好抓
有没有你会吃在80 90这边
然后出场的第一目标大概就150或160
第一目标第二目标可能就是在这里
这样那这时候光是第一目标就已经符合
刚刚我们说那位王同学很厉害的王同学
大概一倍的亏损对上三倍左右
三倍三倍多左右的利潤
这样子
是用这个角度
所以我们不需要知道
现在他到底在走什么东西
那你说互换呢
简单啊
你就给我走出去再走回来
那如果没有呢
我就停嘛
然后再来
再来
短线里面这里的互换
来这个互换很好玩
这个呼唤是我不喜欢的呼唤
你知道为什么吗
老鱼老鱼这边有压力啊
你看这边转支撑了
哦没有哦
他这边很难判断
因为他掉进来这个一堆压力的什么
内侧还外侧
他掉进来里面
所以本来帮忙进攻的做多的军队
这时候也跟着逃跑
所以他们的逃跑上面这堆做多的军队
衝!他們的逃跑就會反過頭來踩到自己人
你如果在這邊做多很不容易判斷
一不小心就被他們踩得頭破血流
這樣
GoPro是嗎?
GoPro大噴是不是?
我有GoPro但是忘記去買GoPro的股票
哦
這什麼東西
前兩天有我們很常見的這種下影線
是說他沒有什麼標準圖
我不敢说他是标准图
他了不起就是下不去下不去你丢一些试试看
是不是该出的喔
来我这样讲好了
你都已经从0.6赚到1.8赚了2到3倍了
你就出一出吧
1万块变成2-3万
对吧
就出一出了吧
你把多出来的钱拿去随便丢一些其他股票
这不是很好吗
对不对
这应该是GoPro吧
是说GoPro我自己在用
我觉得他们那个防震的能力真的还蛮强的
我觉得我在那边跳来跳去什么的
他的画面拍出来还是很稳定
我甚至还要把它拿来别在我的帽子上
然后跟我儿子在丢球
我想要看那个丢球的感觉
但是GoPro其实有点重
所以那个帽子要挑一下
然後他還有附一個那種可以黏在安全帽上的那種卡榫這樣子
這個這邊很難判斷喔
比較好判斷的位置在這裡
然後CRM出場是不是
我同學們都做很多股票
這裡好像也可以看CRM
這個出場很漂亮
很漂亮你出的點也是一大堆日線的這種點
哇這個出的超漂亮的
Google
Google很好啊
沒有什麼問題 Google
最近這個區域附近我不敢說是哪個精準的點
但是這個區域附近正好都是這裡
而這一週我覺得算關鍵喔
因為這一週是難得
平平以后的下杀
下杀以后来今天的关键的句子是
应该继续杀却没有杀
如果被救援回来像这一周今天礼拜二
如果被救援回来哦
那在这周的后半段如果还留在这边
他就会让周线变成是长下影线
我喜欢周线在这边长下影线
哇这个是很棒的
好不好
GoPro很多人稱讚產品為何股價跟10億啊
我不知道耶 因為可能有人說中國那邊 例如說那個什麼360然後說屌打GoPro什麼的 事實上360還真蛮强的这个我去试用他们的产品也没话说所以竞争者多了
那自然股价就下来了
他最一开始就没有竞争者
他是第一个
对
IB有建仓了吗
我都还没有建次月份的仓位
还没有
来来来
老鱼刚刚在说这边没有很好
做多有没有看到
有没有看到
我在讲你没有在听
对不对
Gogoro还有救吗
我不知道
反正我手上买Gogoro的钱
我就打算
因为那个是多的
我当时就某一段地方有赚钱
我就拿来直接丢
所以亏了任何钱我都无所谓
我就丢我想说要报个十年
反正我有騎夠夠了啊
就這樣子吧
今天下午不知道什麼消息
就一直跌
對啊今天就一直跌啊
上面我看一下還有哪些同學
系立KY
想知道
好啦我看一下
系立喔
系
系列是什么东西呢
不是这个系列
系
这里这里
下次给我号码好了
给我号码我比较好找
你是买在昨天的最低点
这是今天
如果你买在昨天的最低点
你会被我打屁股
你知道为什么吗
来
昨天这是一根
由上往下满满的
下沙的K棒
应该就是这支嘛
对不对
细地KY
对啊
那你买最低点
代表你买在最后面
下沙的这里
你就是赌而已
没有没有
这个没有任何人在支撑你
对吧
来口诀给大家
很凶的个股
很凶的K棒
一定要等一个什么
原地停顿
不然它很容易
后面还有会有
很凶的渔波荡漾
就像今天这样子
好吗
你等今天之後
你再來說
好我把這一天當做參考點這個大戶買上來的大戶我拿他的屍體當盾牌在这边开始慢慢建仓虽然是吃在跟你差不多的价格甚至可能还贵一些些
但是这个是比较稳定
而且比较好去防守的东西
不然你刚下杀第一个
你就是那个人家拿来当盾牌的
那个挡箭牌
不要啦
以后不要这样子做
OK
小鈉好像要出現破反的
哦不行哦 等一下
剛好我們在EK裡面
這樣子的東西就算來到這邊我碰都不想碰了
你知道為什麼嗎
為什麼
他應該要直接這樣上去才對
所以這邊的這個瞬間
我不喜歡
老魚上去了
我不管 我要退一步
因為我剛剛看到的圖就是常常上影線
哦~~現在變成又上去了勒
好吧,我被他嚇跑了,掰!我不做
我沒有辦法,因為我們現在都是未來人
我們都是看到上面的結果
然後才回頭這樣子
不要啦,好不好
那如果來你到大一點的刻度,請問哦
大一点的刻度
反而比较漂亮
我如果刚刚看的是5K
我说不定敢吃
但我刚刚一切过来是1K
那我就不吃
你有没有看到两边的
我两边的计划是完全不一样的事情
那如果我刚刚是15K
哇!其实15K喔!来!
15K这个尖尖的隔壁这里
会是我很喜欢的东西
这个
这是我习惯的东西
这位同学
你是用什么
这该不会是付费聊天吧
这个YEN同学谢谢你
这应该不是付费吧
不要啦
你加入会员27个月
感谢你
你是我的衣食父母
我说真的哦
我的交易法
一点都不难
我只是帮大家点进来
所以其实大家要感谢的是自己
可能你可以回头去感谢一下自己的家人不是付费就好了还好还好因为你要感谢的是你自己经过这段时间的沉淀跟利店
市场上面的风风雨雨
已经比较不会
不会让你的信念
让你的思想跟着那些风雨这样飘来飘去
这个我不是很想吃的
这个图好烂哦
他待会来
待会如果再这样下来
15k这里
带着这两个上影先这样下来
我这个好硬哦
no no no
这个连5K的图都变烂了
那更不用讲1K的
不要哦不要哦
现在道琼15分K的图
我看一下
道琼
15哦
要怎么判断
你是只判断要做多吗
刚刚的15分K
所以你应该刚刚在问我的时候的15分K
应该是像这样子
我问一下刚刚这位同学
是不是像这样子
最新的一根还没出现
你说问我这样该怎么判断吗
你是想要问我这件事吗
不用怎么判断
涂鸦还有两条线
两条线画出来
拜拜结案
那这里怎么吃
这个吃法就不是五分K的吃法
这个吃法就可能是更短刻度的事情
也不是15K的吃法
这样好不好
所以原来大家可以这样发言是不是
这样发言坦白讲我比较看得到
最新的一根出现的是十字线
好那我就用这个来当案例
我现在没有会员群组了
我现在没有在帮大家改作业了
因为我发现以前改作业花掉了我
大量的脑细胞都死光光
好累
如果是这张图出现在这里
我会怎么看
我不怎么看
这个15K就不是属于我的机会
我怎么样都下单不了
这样
各位这样可以理解我的意思吗
你知道为什么我下单不了吗
它不符合我的任何一个地方可以吃啊
除非在
我看一下1分K有没有
1分K
都是很勉強
如果是5K,了不起你要賭的是賭
這一根瞬間收回來的瞬間
你那個賭,然後
你還是很賭這樣子
可能沒有比32大了吧
我還要連群組同學算在裡面
是哦
如果是群組同學那已經是
已經是不知道多久了
因為有一些同學其實跟了可能有十年之久吧
這樣
其實我說真的
在我們以前在教的那個小群組裡面
厲害的同學好多
比我厲害的太多了
選股很強的一堆
然後短線打很厲害的一堆
所以大家都臥虎藏龍的藏在大家的身邊這樣
OK
好啦
那
我要特别回来讲这个
你说怎么判断这件事
你其实是因为
因为市场好像走
你刚刚有点想下单
但是没有按下去
但是市场open出了
所以你就回来问我说
老鱼像这种怎么办
应该有这种
这种有点
犹豫又后悔的感觉在里面
那实际上的行情
我们都不知道未来
所以你能做的就只是按下去做的决定
赔就赔
例如说像我今天我乱按
那我就要想办法控制
我不要按到一个很夸张的地步
我允许我乱个1000多美金
好了顶多就这样子
就这样子
好不好
所以不要
不要因为行情走出去
而回头说我应该怎么吃到那个点
如果是纯15K
这个没有什么好机会可以吃
那如果呢
你说看这种
发现自己看不懂要多还是空
对不对
那我问你
你为什么要随时都看得懂多还是空
如果你在这边这么久
那你应该常常听我说
我在那边皱着眉头犹豫
说这个我也看不懂
我也不知道
这里尴尬
喷出了
好没关系吧
你应该常看我这样子吧常看我在在猶豫说我也不是很懂这样我们就很宽心的放开心胸的接受
我们就一定会有看不懂的时候
甚至绝大多数的时候都是我看不懂的时候
嗯
你相信吗
大多数的时候都是我看不懂
但是偶尔你会遇到一些我懂了
好那个点
来我告诉你这张图
什么时候会变成我懂的样子
如果刚刚你的这个
你说刚刚是十字线大概长这样子
对不对
这张图先借我用
这样哦
什么时候会长成我懂的样子
如果他有打
如果他没有前面这个
如果他没有前面这个哦
这样子对不对
然后直接就把这边走出去
这个时候
带个长长的上引线下来
中间大K棒下来回到这个地方
我相信你知道我要讲什么
来到这里
那这样子就是会懂的地方
对吧
那他多了这个
所以他让我在判断这个的时候会很犹豫
就是上面时薪这么大
又有这个
卡在中间看不懂
所以在这一瞬间你要做的事情两个
1. 进到更小刻度去看
你看一下1K有没有东西
1K你可能勉强吃在
我不敢说
或是5K或是3分K
我不知道你可能进到
唯一能吃的点大概就5K
下来一上来的瞬间
吃在940这里
然后防守这个地方
顶多是这样子
但是这些都还不是我们很习惯的标准动作的点
如果你是前一段时间让我看到这里的5K
这个
这样好了
这个的5K的隔壁这里我会吃
只要我看到我就吃了边界二吃
这个
大家应该知道嘛
那这个就是我讲的我终于看得懂的东西
这样这是其中一种嘛
对吧
然後或是出現這邊這個互換居然被人家用一個小整理戳下去回覆下不去,好耶,邊界的隔壁開始如果是这样子这种我都看得懂但是刚刚这个我看不懂 所以我没跟上这一段
那我猜小纳应该也碰了 对不对
是不是
相对起来
小纳的5k或15k可能
小纳的15k顶多只有这里
这都是抓着那个边界在摸的
或是5K的这里
有啦 顶多是抓后面下影线回来的这里
了不起是这样子
如果在1K说不定很少 前面很少啊
这里很少啊
很少大K棒下沙扫完下不去
你吃在这个附近 这个我会给过哦
因为这个是这种大K棒走这么远
隔壁应该要鱼坡当样下去
該下去下不去的1分K的就只有這裡
這個能吃單大概在9、8或100這邊
這樣
好不好
你說我有沒有看蜘蛛人
有我看蜘蛛人
蜘蛛人這次我覺得蠻好看的拍的很好啊
而且那個Tom Holland都自己做他的特技
我覺得不簡單
這樣
好不好
好啦,TS出現台灣之光
王建民
不知道,不過剛剛那個王同學在這裡剛剛有講
他就是那位王同學
是不是
所以如果
喔!
這位同學厲害耶,累積差不多2萬美金的閒錢
IB增倉演練
歡迎啊!
你都已經可以在TS這邊累積出來了
沒有問題
絕對沒有問題
哇!同學都很厲害
太厉害了
那我跟你说
你接下来做的事情是这样子
你把这2万丢去IB以后
不要再希望TS能够继续帮你提供资金
先暂时不要
因为一旦你希望
TS能够帮你提供IB的资金的时候
你TS的那个金钱感就跑出来
你反而会做不好
你跑去IB这2万美金就慢慢来
有好了股票这边丢个1000丢个2000丢个1000丢个2000
你分個十等份慢慢吃,二十等份也沒關係
一次一千兩千,一千兩千慢慢吃
就把你的部位堆疊起來這樣,很好啊很好很好
那
他就是王先生
真的吗
我看账号
我没有仔细
诶说不定是
诶
我有经过Live
有啊
在那时候两阶段考试的时候
我那时候有考过
很早了我讲到两阶段考TS
大家就知道那是多早以前的事情了
那时候有拿到一个live
那个live我拿蛮久的
好一段时间
然后后来那个live也是某一次
就是后来爆胀流出来
那我一个不爽就跑去把那个live
我就想说我也学爆胀流
然后真的就爆胀就拜拜
所以我觉得没有必要用那个报仗流
那个是那种赌法
那摆明就是赌博
赌什么
试着把平台那边的钱用某种方式把它赌出来
但是那样子做法的人
不得不值得称自己
不配称自己为交易者
因为你打从一开始就不是用正规交易的角度切入的
你是用风险很低
讀讀讀讀买一堆账号然后讀出来的这种
这样
好吗
好啦那我们今天又准备要下课
我我我我
对啊好不好
来
最后一张投影片
已经连续三个礼拜都用这个
我要叫我老婆再丢一些照片给我了
能在国外买到我要出版的时候
出版社说他们会有电子版
就是就是電子書跟實體書會同步上市
這樣好不好
那我要先跟大家說我要打預防針喔
這本書並不是買來
然後所有的東西在裡面
你光看這本書就夠了
好不好
我盡可能的篩
但是我認為其實
我認為啦
我沒有辦法把所有直播裡講到的東西
都一次篩完在這本書
我如果要全部篩完
那說真的
其實我就把直播的字幕
全部檔轉出來全部收錄起來這樣就好了
對不對
那一定要經過練習
他不是看完就哇神功護體這種事情
好嗎他一定要經過練習
那我盡量的把我們的know how
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:30:00 起〕